invité les étudiants à donner leur
regard sur le handicap c'est l'objectif
du concours tous en scène 400 étudiants
mobilisés sans vidéo réalisée et une
comédie musicale celle de l'association
backstage d' hec
les élèves de jouy en josas sont venus à
la cérémonie de remise des prix
ils représentent leurs projets en faveur
d'enfants atteints du cancer
l'idée c'est de réussir à créer une
journée thématique pour leur redonner le
goût leur donner le goût de l'art de
l'expérience de la scène mais aussi à
travers un cadre très intimiste la
visite des coulisses avec nous et de la
10ème à la rencontre avec les différents
acteurs du monde de la comédie musicale
elles sont assez isolé et il nous
raconte beaucoup aussi que même leur vie
sociale et c'est vraiment diminué depuis
qu'ils ont eue cancer est donc cet
événement cette opportunité en fait
c'est le basset on peut à faire un grand
événement avec plusieurs jeunes qui ont
tous à la terrible maladie prix humour
sport ou coup de coeur il faudra
attendre la fin de la soirée avec les
prix mobilisation établissements pour
connaître la réponse
l'association obtient le troisième prix
de sa catégorie et repart avec une
enveloppe de 1000 euros mais la tension
qui monte pitié rechute et donc c'est
vrai qu'au moment où ils ont annoncé mme
privat on s'y attendait pas du tout et
c'était vraiment un plaisir pour nous ça
représente
beaucoup parce que ça veut dire que le
campus est aussi un peu sensibles à nos
projets qui nous a suivis qui nous a
encouragés
ils servent indiscutablement à ouvrir
ces jeunes un spectacle mais ça peut
être aussi à des études ça peut être
d'autre chose et on est très contents
que hec et ce troisième prix un montant
qui les aidera à financer leur spectacle
du 6 mai à paris mais pour mener à bien
ce projet ils ont encore besoin de 600
euros
un objectif qu'ils espèrent atteindre
grâce à une cagnotte lancé sur internet